ladies and gentlemen thank you for  visiting and we hope you enjoyed the  show freddy and the gang are pretty  tired but they'll be back again next  week after a few days of scheduled  maintenance  freddy fazbear's mecca pizza plex has  now closed initiating nighttime  protocols no no wait i'm still here  my god  i want you  boys  [Music]  you should be able to escape when the  security doors reopen at 6am  until then keep moving and try not to  draw attention to yourself if there is  another way out i will help you find it  i promise  [Music]  [Music]  please make your way to the front of the  building where you will be given novelty  glasses a voucher for one free soda  refill and where you will sign a legal  disclaimer releasing us of all liability  for anything that might have happened  during your visit  have an awesome night and we'll see you  again soon  [Music]  would you like to take a short survey  about your experience